[Music] I've
never seen you work so hard until now, but it's not like anything happened. If you're going to lie, just tell a
lie that's hard to understand. I've already applied for the
use of the training ground all at once, and I'm
also taking classes.  I heard you haven't been slacking off. Even though you
left once, you're still using your dorm room. I
'm not blaming you. Look, college
is a place where guardians train, so there
's no problem.  Well, it's fine as long as
there's no problem, right? That's fine,
but the more motivated
I am, the more I end up doing something unreasonable. Me too. I carried
out the experiment slowly and carelessly, and
this is the result. So,
while I was conscious, I realized that my notation was a
Buddha.  It's
clear
now that partial mutations, natural
changes, injuries and deficiencies are considered honorable,
but in the
past they were laughed at, and an inconvenience is an inconvenience. You
have to hide from people. I guess it's no
good for young people.
[Music]
It's a mess.  You said
something frustrating, so I'm
just going to make it go away.
[Music] You
can increase the maximum number of balls you can use and the targets. I'll
split the budget with you.